can I just say how awesome this year has
been so far and to top it off we have
some amazing full anime for 2023 with
just a few weeks left I'm so excited to
share with you my top picks for the
season of course our opinions may change
as we watch more but that's all part of
the fun right we can always look back
later and see how our thoughts have
evolved so let's dive in and enjoy this
amazing season of anime together let's
get on with it here are my top 10 new
anime for fall 2023 hope you enjoy it
starting this season review is kingdoms
of ruin
[Music]
how some edginess to start your day hey
edgy really is the key word to describe
kingdoms of ruin a Witch Hunt a quest
for vengeance lots and lots of violence
and a protagonist who tethers between
the role of a hero and a ruthless
villain you kind of get where this is
going right it's not exactly a
mind-blowing premise and a world that
kingdoms of Ruin promises us but overall
it manages to entertain especially with
the whole thing looking like a
magnificent train wreck and you know
that's not always a negative description
for those who've been around the anime
scene for a while it's got its Target
demographic and if you have an affinity
for revenge stories that don't pull back
on the violence and the tragedy as well
as some fan service mind you you'll love
kingdoms of
Ruin Ron gon aashi's forbidden
deductions come
[Music]
next
as a pallet cleanser from the intense
emotions from kingdoms of Ruin why not
try a fun detective mystery forbidden
deductions fits the bill perfectly as a
relatively light-hearted show that
manages to be very engaging if you
remember the millionaire detective from
a couple of years ago you generally have
an idea of what the Fe of this anime is
going to be like it's got some appeal
with its twists on the whole Sherlock
Holmes premise and while it starts
slowly and takes on a mystery of the
week format the characters and they're
pretty entertaining interactions do
their job of keeping me watching while
it success to an audience largely hinges
on how well the reception of the
characters is there are some laughs to
be had with this brand of Comedy overall
a good watch that you probably won't
regret even if it's not something that
will completely stand out and be the
anime of the
Season berserk of gattin also finds its
way onto our
list berserk of gluty is quite a strange
case it's something that I've looked
forward to entering the season a lot
mainly due to the aesthetic appeal
that's pretty much my jam it does look
pretty cool when it has quite an
interesting premise too but Midway
through the season and reception to the
series has been quite mixed for good
reason it's mostly due to how the story
seems to meander around after the first
few episodes being quite random and
actually straying from The Source
material a bit still for what it has to
offer it does remain quite good berserk
of glat has Nifty fight scenes and the
story does progress at a fair speed even
the developments can be quite random as
I've said it's a Zero to Hero an
underdog rising up against the world
story that will more than satisfy your
cravings for one it's serviceable
overall for what it aims to do
characters that aren't too deep but have
their quirks fights that can be
enjoyable but not coming with eye
popping animation and the like you get
the
picture we continue with the fantasy
anime train ride for our next entry is
ragar RS
[Music]
him ragna Crimson is another of the
fantasy titles that I look forward to in
my preseason video it's got a little of
everything that you typically want from
a dark fantasy anime engaging characters
a gripping narrative and a bit of
special Intrigue with a familiar World
being Chief amongst those to that end I
think that ragna Crimson does pretty
well for itself with what I've seen so
far however for someone who's read the
Manga The Experience may fall a bit
short of expectations ragna Crimson also
has the underdog story elements that
have seemingly become a staple in the
action anime world all while maintaining
its gloomy Vibes there's the question of
aoral forces seemingly on the side of
the protagonist and it uses that to hook
you in on an adventure that really gets
you into it ragar Crimson is likely my
pick for you if you have an itch for
Dark Fantasy that needs to be scratched
for what it's supposed to do it does it
with a lot of
Competency next up we take a look at the
first romcom 100
[Music]
girlfriends right off the bat 100
girlfriends does away with the pretense
it has a wacky premise and it runs with
it all the way giving you sound
expectations of what you'll be getting
in this Haram romcom and it really works
in multiple ways too especially for
people who are fond of the Haram genre
the cool thing about harams or at least
shows with a large core female cast is
how they can Market themselves to the
target audience with that many
characters and their stories explored
bit by bit there'll always be someone
for you to like the success of that
aspect hinges on how well the story can
elaborate on said characters and make
you care and 100 girlfriends does that
pretty well with this brand of Comedy
people have been saying is the funniest
anime of the season and while I agree
with that I also find it nice that it
can shift gears when needed the premise
means that the girls won't find as much
opportunity to grow at least not as in-
depth as those who want deep romantic
development but given the context of the
premise and the resulting hilarity I'd
say it works out just fine
[Music]
I what you can do however is to hit that
like button if you're enjoying this kind
of content shanga Frontier is here to
give us more craziness off the
[Music]
break shangula Frontier is an anime that
wastes no time making a strong first
impression people have called it a
surprise of the season but you can't say
that I didn't see it coming but this is
already looking mighty promising for a
video game show in terms of Mass Appeal
and grabbing your attention there's no
beating shangry La Frontier it wastes no
time pulling you into it whether it be
through the bright and colorful world
the charismatic main character but just
how well it presents video games people
have called this a love letter to Gamers
and you can clearly see it with the
execution and how the story is being
told honestly it does feel refreshing
for once to have a video game anime
about well a guy playing a video game
without many repercussions for once the
game itself and how it works plays a
large role in the narrative in a more
direct way no isekai is and no video
games being a hook only to be thrown to
the Wayside once the proper genre of the
anime like drama or Romance man take
Center Stage the last anime to capture
that feel for me is bofuri and that was
another show that I liked whether you're
someone raring for video game anime or
not give shanga Frontier a try much of
what makes it click can't be adequately
expressed in words you'll just have to
experience it
yourself we then move on to Undead
unluck at number
[Music]
four
here's a much anticipated newcomer to
the party Undead unluck like shangar
Frontier made waves with an excellent
first episode a crazy fight scene and a
wild premise that doesn't seem too
outlandish in the world of Shonen this
is an anime that got off to a pretty hot
start it's a whole lot of fun and not
the Mindless type mind you there's more
to it as it tries to weave its way and
add its unique spin to the tried and
tested shown and tropes it throws at you
you know the insane fights the secret
organizations the crew jokes that pop up
every now and then the winning Shonen
formula if you will much of the
enjoyment however comes from the
chemistry between the two main
characters that are pretty fun Duo
though the way their relationship gets
written isn't exactly anything
groundbreaking it still manages to form
the Cornerstone of what's been so far a
very entertaining title if you want to
pick up a new show to watch want a
little bit of chaos Undead unluck is the
one for you entering our top three now
we begin with the Apothecary
Diaries
they kept us waiting but the grand
opening and debut of the Apothecary
Diaries proved to be a big success the
Apothecary Diaries prevents itself as a
unique show standing out from the rest
of the field with its historical setting
and a different point of emphasis on the
art and Aesthetics it excels in those
fields that greatly help set the tone
and mood for the show what puts it over
the top to be one of the best new anime
the season has to offer has to be the
World building the world and the
character characters all form a pretty
interesting bunch and the first three
episodes which were air back toback turn
out to be a very great hook into the
setting Court dramas aren't new in media
but they've often fascinated me with how
well they eventually delve into politics
and deeper emotional developments and
it's a place I can really see Apothecary
Diaries heading to with over 20 more
episodes for more Mysteries and
developments this is a very very
promising
[Music]
title at number two we have po
PLO Pluto's a sci-fi thriller that
people have been praising nonstop and
it's easy to get caught in the hype and
check it out trust me you won't regret
it one bit it combines some amazing
visuals and sounds with a somber yet
very thrilling story about Humanity's
interaction with technology the
production value is Sky High for Pluto
and I'd say it plays a part in
emphasizing the overall tone and mood
that the series is going for and that's
not even with the characters which can
be said to be the strongest point in
Pluto the character building here is is
pretty remarkable and the way things
were built up makes the payoff very
strong it's this aspect that helps make
the emotional moments in the anime
strike harder than they should Pluto as
a standalone Works decently still it
feels like something that you can enjoy
even further if you have some knowledge
of its source material its parent story
regardless Pluto manages to bring out
some of the best you'd expect from
psychological sci-fi and presents it in
a way that anime viewers can enjoy a lot
full of Thrills Mysteries and action a
great title for sci-fi fans to
binge
[Music]
s ah everyone's pick for the season free
Ren by all metrics is really one of the
best titles The Season's given us
whether it be Story character depth
sound art presentation and the like it
really is the most complete title and
something that can be recommended to to
anyone even those who aren't fans of
anime it's a journey that has a lot to
unpack filled with emotion and moments
to make us rethink life and our position
in the grand scheme of it all I do think
this show deserves to be the number one
anime of the season and it really is if
you're to take a look at it through most
lenses when you look at it the arbitrary
thing holding fre back is that it isn't
for lack of a better term exciting
enough if you catch my drift not that
that's a knock against it but it's
something that the typical young anime
fan of the modern era wouldn't be
running in droves to watch without the
frankly Amazing Word of Mouth it takes
things slow and lets you marinate on its
themes instead of blitzing through the
plot and giving us spectacular fights or
Cliffhangers that keep you waiting kind
of like Vinland Saga 2 as opposed to one
I
[Music]
guess tell me what you think of the list
and the placements down in the comment
section feel free to also recommend some
fall 2023 anime that you think deserves
some love as usual if you enjoyed the
list hit that like button and share the
Channel with your friends we're still
trying to grow the community here and it
would be awesome if you could keep our
momentum up thank you for watching the
video looking forward to seeing you in
the next one which shouldn't be too long
have a great day